L'une des premières fois où l'on a fait venir un Américain au Japon
pour diriger une équipe de baseball japonaise professionnelle -
Bobby Valentine en 1995 -
il a pris une équipe très médiocre,
l'a menée à une spectaculaire seconde place
et a été viré instantanément.
Pourquoi ?
« Eh bien, a dit le porte-parole de l'équipe,
du fait de son insistance à gagner. »
(Rires)
Le Japon officiel peut très bien sembler être comme ce point
que l'on dit avoir duré deux heures et 12 minutes
et jouer pour ne pas perdre
peut ôter toute l'imagination, l'audace et le plaisir aux choses.
En même temps, jouer au ping-pong au Japon
me rappelle pourquoi les chœurs s'amusent souvent plus que les solistes.
Dans un chœur, votre seule tâche est de jouer parfaitement
votre petite part,
de jouer vos notes avec émotion
et ce faisant, d'aider à créer une harmonie magnifique
qui est bien supérieure à la somme de ses composantes.
Oui, tout chœur a besoin d'un chef d'orchestre,
mais je crois qu'un chœur vous libère
de la notion simple qu'un enfant a de la binarité.
Vous en venez à voir que le contraire de perdre n'est pas de gagner --
c'est manquer de voir la situation dans son ensemble.
Au fil de ma vie,
je suis vraiment effrayé de voir qu'aucun événement
ne peut être correctement évalué avant des années.
Un jour, j'ai perdu tout ce que je possédais,
absolument tout, dans un incendie.
Mais avec le temps, j'en suis venu à voir que c'était cette perte apparente
qui m'a permis de vivre sur Terre avec plus de douceur,
d'écrire sans notes
et de déménager au Japon
où il y a cette salle de sport intérieure connue sous le nom de table de ping-pong.
A l'inverse, je suis un jour tombé sur le travail parfait
et j'en suis venu à voir qu'un bonheur apparent
peut faire obstacle à une vraie joie
bien plus que le malheur.
Jouer en double au Japon me soulage de toute mon anxiété
et à la fin de la soirée,
je remarque que tout le monde part
dans un état de ravissement plus ou moins similaire.
On me rappelle chaque soir
que ne pas avoir plus de points n'équivaut pas à en avoir moins,
que le fait de ne pas être plein de vie équivaut à être mort.
J'en suis venu à comprendre pourquoi
on dit que les université chinoises offrent des diplômes de ping-pong
et pourquoi les chercheurs ont découvert que le ping-pong
pouvait aider dans le cas d'un trouble mental léger
et même de l'autisme.
Quand je regarderai les Jeux olympiques 2020 à Tokyo,
j'aurai parfaitement conscience
qu'il ne sera pas possible de dire qui a gagné ou qui a perdu
avant très longtemps.
Vous souvenez-vous de ce point que j'ai évoqué
qui est dit avoir duré deux heures et 12 minutes ?
Un des joueurs de ce match a fini, six ans plus tard,
dans les camps de concentration d'Auschwitz et de Dachau.
Mais il en est sorti vivant.
Pourquoi ?
Simplement parce qu'un garde de la chambre à gaz
l'a reconnu de ses jours de joueur de ping-pong.
Avait-il été le gagnant de ce match épique ?
Cela ne comptait guère.
Comme vous vous en souvenez, de nombreuses personnes étaient parties
avant même que le premier point ne soit conclu.
La seule chose qui l'a sauvé
fut le fait qu'il avait participé.
La meilleure façon de gagner n'importe quel match,
me dit le Japon un soir sur deux,
est de ne jamais, jamais penser au score.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)